on the middle of the scoreboard yep  a4  wesley  didn't magnus play like f3 king f2  against wesley at some point he's been  experimenting he did that  he did f3 against duda  in the champions chester he did h4  against um  wei yi  yeah d3 c3 i think he also played f3  king f2  against wesley yeah he did did in some  classical not a classical game in some  rapid blitz game online  and uh okay how is he going to make  a4 make sense so i'm guessing he has to  follow that up with  d4 or something but he's gone for some  retty setup a4 is not that weakening  probably white white is not that much  worse  but of course black isn't but shouldn't  you be responding with e5 so all these  uh a5s h5s  i haven't studied that much a4 theory  yet i i know there are